tough times for Donald Trump you don't
know what I'm talking about yeah please
please please vote later okay just vote
that's the important thing political
analysts say that after their
embarrassing loss on health care the
White House is desperately looking for a
win desperately looking for a win which
is why this week they're playing the
Lakers
I bet Trump shoots the basket that way
[Applause]
it went in it went in it went in they
wouldn't know it didn't go it went in
totally went in Joe Biden is now saying
he regrets not running for president
yeah and after last week Donald Trump
said he also regrets that Joe Biden
didn't run for president someone noticed
this someone notices it's come out that
President Trump has spent nearly
one-third of his presidency in a trump
branded property yeah and folks that's
not even counting his wife Melania
[Applause]
this is basically a children show except
for the nipple part this weekend Donald
Trump met with the Congressional Black
Caucus yep yeah because you know what
they say once you go black caucus you
never go back caucus
well that's one you either laugh at or
don't but it doesn't deserve this
applauding seems to fill things out
nicely
officials in Columbia this is crazy
officials in Columbia are angry at
rapper Wiz Khalifa for smoking marijuana
at the tomb of Pablo Escobar yeah
they're mad at him
Columbia officials said marijuana has no
place at this sacred monument to cocaine
that that isn't right another drug
related story in India poppy farmers
this is real are complaining that opium
addicted parrots are destroying their
farms we're stealing the poppies yeah
even worse the parrots won't stop saying
Polly wants to blast off
you
you